hey everyone this is IA roadkill and i
am going to attempt to explain how to
use the crop rotation planner for
seasons in farming simulator 19
I need to add a disclaimer right now I
play on the PlayStation 4 I do not have
access to seasons I've watched numerous
videos and I can see that everyone is
struggling with the idea I think I might
know how it's done so I'm gonna make
this video I invite people that are on
the PC to try my method see if it works
and let me know if I have mentioned
something incorrectly I will correct it
that way we have a good video out there
on how to set up your planner so let's
get started
I don't have access to the game so I'm
using a spreadsheet on my Mac so here is
my number little page that I built your
crop rotation is vertical going from the
top down step 1 pick a field to plan so
for this example we're gonna say it's
called field 1 go to the field and look
at the history for that field I believe
it will say 2 years prior what it had
last year and what it had the year
before that keep a mental note of those
two crops
step two key in the history for the
field field one in this case now before
you do any plowing I don't know if it
would remove the history if you plowed
or not by keying in the history I mean
go to the first open field at the top on
the left's call left column which we're
calling field one and key in the crop
that would have been the oldest or two
years ago in this case we're gonna say
that it was fallow
in the next field down you want to key
in the prior year or last year's
what was in the ground right now what
can you see his stubble and for this
example we'll say it was wheat we don't
know that it was wheat but it would be
labeled as cereal so pick something that
was a cereal crop you now have the
history of that field in your system so
that you can start a good plan step 3
start adding your crop ideas for this
year on the next open slot you want to
look for the best percentage on the
column to the right of that one point
zero zero being neutral one point two
being better 0.9 being worse you want to
get the highest number possible of a
fruit or crop that you want in the next
year play around with different crops
and see what you can get for the highest
percentage remember that this slot is
for what you are going to plant this
spring step 4
repeat step 3 for your year 2 of the
game in other words go to the next box
down and you want to try different crops
until you get the best percentage for
that year
now repeat step 4 until you have your
sheet filled out for as many years as
you want if your rotation only has 3
years
of different crops that's fine you don't
have to use all of them but there are up
to six spaces remember you can only use
four of your own crops at the present
time because we have two crops in
history at the top
you
at this point you have the first field
field one planned for the next four
years and it would be time to plan field
number two which is the next one to the
right field number three which is the
third one field number four which would
be the fourth one or the farthest one to
the right we're not going to fill those
in right now we'll just pretend you only
have one field and that's all you're
concerned about after year one is over
in other words you're in spring one of
year two
okay or you could do it in winter but
it's easier to explain if you are in the
next year or spring one step eight is to
move all the planner entries up one line
so you're going to remove line one
history field from step number two and
move everything up
the next step
is to add the next crop idea in this
case it would be for year five to get
the best percentage after year two is
over
in other words spring one of year three
you'll want to repeat this last steps
again move all your planner entries up
one line removing line one history of
field from step two
and add another crop idea in this last
open slot
cleared out again remember you don't
have to add all of them but you may as
you enter this last time keep an eye on
what that's going to do to your year one
that is now at the top of the list it
will affect your rotation when you start
this over again remember that this is
only a planner for your benefit
it does not affect how the game runs I
hope this hasn't been too confusing I
hope it has simplified how the procedure
would work again if you have any
suggestions please leave them in the
comments and I can correct any errors
that I have made I'd like to thank
everyone who stayed to watch the entire
video if you found it enjoyable or
educational I would appreciate it if you
would hit that like button and also hit
that subscribe button I'd like to wish
everyone including you a very wonderful
day good bye for now
you